hello and welcome back to steampunks the
GameSpot show where we tell you all the
cool new PC games that come out on Steam
every week I'm Edmund Tran I'm Joe and I
must say it's been a very very big week
for PC games this week so hopefully you
will enjoy the show Jess what did you
play alright so the first game I played
this week is called for the king it's a
roguelike but more accurately a
roguelike I love the fact that it's a
roguelike this game is a pretty
traditional RPG it's divided into a hex
overworld there's different things on
each tile and you have up to three
characters so it's a little strange and
the fact that each character moves
individually but you need to keep them
grouped so for example you can send them
off in different directions but when
they get into combat scenario say you
end encounter an enemy tile on the map
you will get into a combat with all of
the allies and enemies within a certain
range so if your allies are too far away
they won't fight with you and that's a
really big problem I think one of the
reasons they did it that way is you're
also kind of on a timer with this game
chaos is kind of coming to screw up the
world and you need to make quite a lot
of progress in your main mission quests
to eliminate chaos so the world doesn't
become really terrible and every time
you bump your timeline into another
session of chaos the enemies get
stronger and the entire game gets harder
so combat is pretty simple you have
three or so attacks that are dependent
on your weapon type if you lose all four
of your lives and have to bring people
back to life four times then you cannot
bring people back to life again and
that's when you can lose your entire
party if there's a mechanic where you
can commit focus to an action to make
the chance of it being successful climb
so you can do that when you're attacking
something or when you're exploring
something in the environment but it's
still really down to the rng gods
we'll just came out of early access
didn't it it did just come out of early
access yeah
so if you do die and you lose everybody
the one thing you get to keep is law so
law is a really rare resource and you
can spend them on buying things that's
that is outside of the game like new
classes new encounters that will be in
your next
ashin that said since there's the
constantly threatening impending chaos
timeline there is the feeling that you
need to hurry from main objective to
main objective which is kind of a shame
because there's a lot of interesting
things to be found if you explore all
the tiles there's quite a dense
inventory and stat system certain things
you encounter in the environment will
roll for a specific stats so you'll want
to send a specific hero there who's
particularly strong in it alongside that
deciding on the best weapons to equip is
pretty interesting as they all do quite
different things some target one unit
some target multiple I think this game
has a lot of potential and a lot of
elements are working really well I think
it would be really great if it was a
single party I see why they did what
they did so you kind of need to balance
between exploration and making sure your
party stays together but overall I think
it's a really enjoyable RPG and I mean
it played more than four hours of it now
so it's definitely a game that keeps
pulling you back in
you want to talk about complex games yes
I'm gonna talk about Battletech which
just came out this week it's a battle
tech for those who don't know is like a
decades-old tabletop game about giant
western-style mechs and the people that
pilot them it's the franchise that
inspired the mega popular mech warrior
games from the 90s but while those games
were more action based and focus on like
piloting your mech battle tech is a
strategy game and much more faithful to
the original source material in fact
it's headed up by Jordan Wiseman who
created battle Tech in the first place
it literally feels and plays like a
tabletop or board game so for example
when you run to a point and you gain
invasion stacks like a maiden points
which means future attacks against you
have a greater chance of missing and
that kind of simulates the idea of
moving quickly so it's very board game
like when you move your mech you have to
arrange an orientation wheel torso so
you have to pivot in order to face your
enemies to put them in your firing range
or you might want to pivot away from
them to ensure that when they attack
they hit only your left side and right
side there's heat so like when you do
things like fire guns or like jump with
your boosters it will generate heat from
your mech and overheating means that
your metal have suffered structural
damage which means you'll have to repair
it again later you know each mech has a
bunch of different weapons and you know
there might be different weapons like
laser guns and like ballistic weapons
and missiles some guns on me more useful
in some situation the others so you can
turn them off depending on what you want
to fire it is also a whole strategy
layer we actually build and customize or
you mix and then there are a bunch of
different models that you can choose
from and you can customize the amount of
armor on each body part to what weapons
they carry and where how many heat sinks
they have that boost is all that stuff
you know also hire pilots instead of
each pilot has their own some experience
as an RPG sort of skill tree or based on
how they like to pilot and you know then
they can die in sort of every match as
well this is a game to play very very
carefully the whole overarching sort of
meta game is that you maintain this
mercenary group for hire it's easy
really easy to get up to speed if you
want to put the work in if you haven't
come across it before but it's also very
easy to take at face value if you just
don't care one thing I will say to
people who aren't familiar with battle
tech and I sort of interested in this
it's an exceedingly slow game but yeah
this is this game has so much depth in
detail - it's sort of strategy
actually plotting through its entirety
because I'm reviewing at the games but
so if you are interested hopefully you
can find the review on site shortly if
it's not already up so bad I'll take
it's 40 bucks on Steam it's pretty
pricey but it's a big game and if you
know you like this kind of 90 style sort
of deep complex strategy game then
you'll probably like battle tech if you
like the look of it you probably will
like it alright well moving right along
to something a bit less complicated and
something a lot more familiar the other
game I played this week is another rogue
light called the sort of deter so this
one has a gorgeous cartoonish type art
style that is really unique and lovely
and a really great soundtrack and it
functions a ton like Zelda basically
you'll be running about through a town
and overworld areas before going into
dungeons you'll be slashing with your
sword you have four different items that
you can assign on a d-pad so your total
goal is that you want to kill off this
sorceress and you have four days to do
it so if you let those four days take
down more Moe wins but a new sword will
have arisen so think of it kind of like
Slayers in Buffy the Vampire Slayer one
Falls another one Rises you get to keep
your levels when you die so you
basically want to become more and more
and more powerful that you get to a
point where you can kill her off when
you level you just get like little buffs
to your stats you don't have to assign
things but what you can do is buy or
find stickers that can go on either your
sword helmet or armor slots that add
different buffs and resistances and
things like that much like for the King
swords of dinner has a beautiful world
and it's nice to cut into bushes and
just see what there is to say this
game's also really clever in you know
money falls out of bushes and parts yes
this is a lot like Zelda and you also
get rewarded with a few dollars for just
reading a sign or spending time out and
about so for the you to then need to
hurry from place to place when you don't
happen to be in a town or a dungeon
seems like a strange decision and when I
kind of wish they hadn't made obviously
it does add tension which is a choice
you know you're either gonna be a fan of
or not there's a very childlike Nate
kind of Foundation running this entire
game when you go into your map it's
drawn like a little kids drawing some of
the combat is also really clever so
mostly yeah you're just gonna be
slashing your sword at whatever's in
front of you but you do have other items
as well there are special weapons and
things you can get and a lot of the time
you have to figure out the best way to
take out each monster on top of that
whenever you do respawn maps are
procedurally generated and also dungeons
have a lot of little puzzling elements
which are quite satisfying so if this
does sound like your thing sorts of
ditto is 20 bucks which which is pretty
decent if you want to get old cartoons
alluring
[Music]
all right well tilted it Oh is pretty
bright and cheerful the second game I
played this week is most certainly not
right and cheerful and I'm talking about
Frost Punk which is the new game from
the guys who made this war of mine so
happiness all around so Frost punk is a
real-time strategy game that focuses on
city management
so you're basically overseeing the last
dregs of humanity in a steampunk II
Victorian England but anyway you find
this huge furnace so you fire up the
furnace and you're building the city
around it in concentric circles so your
job is to sort of manage the population
by sending them to work and gather
resources like coal to fuel the furnace
wood to build stuff with as along with
steel and sort of hunting for food
you'll get materials adventure tech tree
they bought more structures increase the
capacity to obtain more materials and
keep your furnace running super hot for
longer and more efficiently and the
workforce are the heart of the game so
you kind of both need to push them for
efficiency and also take care of them so
they don't you know get sick and die
you'll also run some really hard and
depressing problems that plague an
insular society like what do you do with
your sick people and what do you do with
your dead bodies and should we make the
children work and you can pass law
dictating on how your society operates
so there's a whole little legal system
yeah what you can and can't do you can
basically turn your city into a police
state and you can like use your dead as
fuel for the fire for example did I
mention this game was bleak it's you
have to juggle between whether you want
to keep hope alive or make your city
work as efficiently as possible which is
really rough in turn actions will breed
both discontent and hope because people
obviously have conflicting opinions you
can also send scouting parties out to
sort of find more survivors to add to
your city has helped but it's also as
more mouths to feed
so Frost Punk is 30 bucks this has got
some really exceptional presentation it
looks gorgeous and the city management
strategy is very strong so I would
definitely recommend this one
[Music]
all right well on that uplifting note
those are all the games we've got for
you this week but I do let us know if
you saw anything you thought was super
worthwhile or if there's anything you've
got your eye out for next week you can
let us know on twitter i'm at jess
mcdonald and i am at admin track but
thanks for joining us once again and we
will see you next week yeah
you
[Music]